[Music]
these tools are sad they have no home
won't you help them if you really loved
them you'd give them the tresco it's
like a tool penthouse it's Japanese
stamped steel and finish with blue
enamel it's so pretty but not too pretty
still for tools check out these hinges
it opens from both sides Japanese design
right the layouts pretty standard big
compartment below 4 wrenches hammers etc
small compartment up top but it's
configurable and the dividers are metal
so they're tough you're not going to
want to relegate this box to the garage
it's part of the decor and you'll have
your tools Within Reach
so you can fix stuff
you
[Music]